[Musique]
le mal le parfum des hommes madame non
madame non en instance de coiffage
il ya une mangue à quoi de faire sa pub
elle la nouvelle collection qui va
partir les gens sont parfois ne vous
allez voir ça va cartonner pas pour
aller au ski régnard
jose antiquités dans son dos au milieu
[Musique]
tu es fan de quittant jamais d'accord je
ne vois pas je suis on dirait plutôt
d'accord et toi tu es fan de qui défont
à bisous à tous
[Musique]
yvon guay
sarah connor bonjour
alors sarah connor
tracts à la vista des grandes et manor
[Musique]
j'ai mal aux pieds
la nouvelle mesure de l'est
est ce qu'on met la perruque aux gens
tout dessus par contre à cause du tabac
et quelques
[Musique]
et
landes
[Musique]
vous
bon anniversaire au pays demande mon
avis non
[Applaudissements]
c'est fait
[Musique]
complet
je bosse
[Musique]